we look at the camera be a star Willie
good morning Hank it's Wednesday and
Willie and I are outside because you
know it's beautiful so Hank your video
about Phineas Gage on Monday made me
think about the human brain god I love
brains I'm like a zombie in two respects
Hank one I love brains two on some
fundamental level I pretty much just
walk around doing whatever I need to do
in order to keep walking around right I
know I love brains I love all the crazy
wonderful things that human brains can
do and today I want to use my knowledge
of brains to definitively solve the
mystery of the poopie Nintendo right so
Mike I'm very familiar with nicer and
Harsha's work in the late 1980s on
flashbulb memories but hey just for
those people who aren't specialist in
the fields of memory science let me tell
you about the famous classic 1989
challenger flashbulb memory study
okay Hank so in 1986 this is very sad
there was a space-shuttle called the
Challenger and as it was going up into
space it blew up and everyone inside of
it died including a teacher named
Christa McAuliffe and there were
millions of schoolchildren all around
America watching this space shuttle
launch because there was a teacher
inside and then we were all you know
horrified the Challenger explosion is
one of those moments where everyone
knows what they were doing and who they
were with when they heard the news and
here are two such stories Story one when
I first heard about the explosion I was
sitting in my freshman dorm with my
roommate and we were watching TV it came
on a news flash and we were really
shocked and I got really upset then I
went upstairs to talk to a friend of
mine and then I called my parents story
- I was in my religion class and people
walked in and started talking about it I
didn't know any of the details except
that it exploded and all the teachers
students had been watching on TV so I
have two very different stories one in
which a person found out about the
Challenger explosion well in religion
class and one in which the person found
out watching TV and that's perfectly
possible there's no problem with that
right buh-buh-buh-buh-buh but the same
person those two stories were recorded
by the same person in this famous study
by nicer and harsh she wrote the
religion class memory the day after the
Challenger explosion and the TV memory
three and a half years later expressing
total confidence in her recollection in
fact almost everyone who participated in
the study remembered three years later
who they were with what they were doing
and how they found out about the tragedy
and yet the vast majority of them were
wrong there is in fact very little
correlation between how well you
remember something and whether that
something happened the brain is not good
at storing accurate memories it's good
at storing narrative memories
wrote a book about this here's what I am
saying Hank I have a flashbulb memory
extremely vivid of discovering red
greens poop in the Nintendo
I believe that memory to be accurate but
after extensive research it would appear
that the only person who physically saw
red greens poop in the Nintendo was me
Hank before him afforded this discussion
I should acknowledge that as a child I
was an inveterate liar as opposed to now
when I am a novelist it is possible that
I created the fiction of red greens poop
in the Nintendo and found that fiction
so credible and compelling that I myself
came to believe it true it's possible
that I have blamed a deceased miniature
dachshund and my blighted brother for
putting poop in a Nintendo that never
had poop in it so Hank I want to
apologize to you I believe that my
broken brain might have created an
incorrect flashbulb memory I also want
to apologize to red green who's bad name
I unfairly besmirched but I can't
apologize to him Hank because he's dead
but I can ask Willie's forgiveness on
behalf of all canine kind Willie would
you like to come over here and perhaps
have all of your dreams come true oh you
would I'm sorry Willie I'm sorry about
my incorrect flashbulb memory do you
forgive me can you ever forgive me Hank
I feel the tongue of forgiveness on my
cheek I will see you on Friday